the constitution of the united states is
a crucial document to understand if
you're a united states citizen and
frankly for almost anyone on the planet
obviously the united states is an
influential country but beyond that
many of the countries out there's
constitutions are actually based on the
united states constitution
so in these lessons we're going to dive
deep we're actually going to read the
constitution and as you'll see we will
read alongside some of the top experts
of the united states constitution in the
world but we'll do it in a way that
you'll realize that you too can be
something of an expert on the united
states constitution we're going to go
through all of the various articles and
sections of the constitution and you'll
find that it's an intriguing document
that has incredible relevance even today
we're also going to talk about how the
judicial system in particular the
supreme court has interpreted the united
states constitution and how that has had
a whole chain of side effects on our
everyday lives and last but not least
we're going to talk about what rights
and liberties are protected by the bill
of rights inside of the united states
constitution so let's go on this journey
together
whether you live in the united states
and really just want to understand the
government that you live in or you're
just a curious mind wanting to
understand how a government can be
structured these lessons will answer
your questions and if you want to learn
more and get deep practice with
immediate feedback i encourage you to
look at these lessons on khanacademy.org